قال رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين
نتنياهو انما سماه الخطر الايرانيه واذرعه
يهدد اسرائيل وامريكا والعالم الحر كله
واضف في مستهل افتتاح الدوره الصيفيه
للكنيسه الاسرائيلي بحضور رئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي كيفن مكارتي ان حكومته
ستبذل كل الجهد لوضع حد لما سماه الخطر
الايراني الدائم
نحن نرى ونبصر التهديد المحديقه بنا من
جانب النظام المتعصب في ايران الذي لا
يهدد اسرائيل وحسب وانما يهدد الولايات
المتحده والعالم الحر كله وسيظل كبح تسلح
ايران نوويا واجبا على راس اولويات
اسرائيل لن نسمح لايران ان تخنقنا بطوق من
الارهاب من سوريا ولبنان وغزه ولن نسمح
لها بالتمركز عسكريا على حدودنا وسنعمل كل
ما يلزم لمنعها من الحصول على سلاح نووي